and to do
I'm looking forward to the upcoming
mortal kombat vs DC universe video game
not because I want to play it Lord no
fighting games have these huge lists of
moves that I always feel like I have to
memorize in order to get anywhere so the
game itself ends up like this extremely
fast extremely violent trivia game 4 45
hit points what is the proper response
when your opponent is launching a double
uppercut chainsaw blast well Bob I
believe the correct answer would be
goodbye sternum up at you so even though
I don't plan on playing the game I am
looking forward to existing as a real
product in the actual universe this is
mostly because the concept is just so
nose poking Lee ludicrous I mean to
begin with there Superman Superman based
interactive entertainment products tend
to be lets say lacking in part this is
because a truly accurate Superman video
game would have one button and it would
be labeled use powers and you would
press it and when so what chance to
sub-zero have against someone who can
picnic on Pluto I mean yeah sub-zero's
powers are magic and that's going to
actually affect Superman but all
Superman has to do is fly into the upper
atmosphere up up high punch and then fry
sub-zero with his heat vision for 50
miles away down back down back low kick
give opponent the finger from sub 0 2
well done in eight seconds flat yeah I
know that some of the other Mortal
Kombat characters are gods and stuff but
the fact remains that they can all be
torn in half by movie star a
vulnerability that is not on Superman's
rather bizarre list of weaknesses but
that's okay you know I am tired of
reasonable matchups the whole enterprise
versus imperial star destroyer thing
exhausted me years ago on the other hand
I'm still intrigued by the idea of an
imperial star destroyer against say the
kontiki especially if you can figure out
a scenario in which the raft wins so
let's do this I desire an endless stream
of fighting
games that pit an unbeatable team
against hapless underdogs here's some
ideas to get you started game designing
folk DC vs AC DC now what I figure is if
a guy named reptile has a chance against
any given member of the Justice League
then Australia's crowd mooning us
rockers should get their shot as well
just as it looks like Angus Young is
down for the count he unleashes his
ultimate final attack youtube AMV
barrage nobody can stand up against
dozens of crabby homemade videos for
highway to hell street fighter vs
strawberry shortcake old version new
version elicit penny arcade version I
don't care i just want to see plum
puddin go up against m.bison
incidentally i also want Street Fighter
to come out with a line of scented dolls
mmm jellied veal soul calibur vs animal
crossing I would actually play this one
I wouldn't play against another person
certainly or for that matter against the
computer i would just said Tom Nook up
as player 2 and I would take a straw and
I would slice him into tanuki patties
here's your mortgage payment tom nook
shall I make the check out to poky
massive lacerations mortal kombat vs
frightened grocery store clerks who
would win an undead ninja or middle-aged
cowering cashier can Raiden possibly
stand up against the incredible power of
a catatonic bad boy and if you beat all
the characters you get to face the final
boss the unmoving lifeless corpse of
Barney kroger everybody vs the guy in
the cafe who is running his entire
business very loudly via cell phone
seriously God
you